this is tony wilson reading for reviewer
mike epstein
the increasingly popular reboot sequel
is a hard needle to thread
you have to create a game that hues
close enough to the original to make
nostalgic fans happy
while modernizing and innovating enough
to resonate with new players
crash bandicoot 4 it's about time
balances the two effortlessly
it impeccably preserves the vibrant look
and feel of the original crash bandicoot
trilogy
while integrating new ideas and
platforming possibilities
and like the original crash games the
hybrid of crash's old and new ideas will
test your platforming skills in
interesting new ways
like its grown inducing dad joke of a
subtitle says
crash 4 is about time travel
when the villains of crash's past open
an interdimensional portal
crash and coco have to collect a set of
quantum masks in order to set things
right
as with the past crash games small
exchanges and cutscenes between levels
do a lot of narrative leg work
it's not much of a story per se but
crash in his friend's charm fills in the
gaps and makes you care enough to follow
along
crash four's time traveling story takes
you to all sorts of times and places
including dinosaur-infested jungles
futuristic cities full of flying cars
and sunken pirate ships every place you
go feels lush
full of color and detail with a
painterly quality that's simply
wonderful to run through
my favorite is the mardi gras world
where crash and spyro balloons float in
the background as you hop over neon
colored flames and trumpet valves
occasionally you'll run through an area
and the camera will pull back to let you
take in the scenery
the environments never failed to impress
me with their visual depth
the best thing i can say about crash 4
is that it mostly feels like classic
crash
in my mind crash's signature is in the
way the camera moves to create different
perspectives from area to area
giving each set of jumps a fresh feel
sometimes you're moving left to right
while other times you're running away
from the camera or bouncing straight up
from box to box
crash 4's long levels are chock full of
carefully plotted platforming sequences
which require quick reflexes and the
ability to think on your feet
the dynamic design changes things up
frequently making every
level feel winding and unpredictable
with every new set of platforms
presenting a surprising
exciting new challenge it still feels
classic
even as it introduces new mechanics once
you find each of the quantum masks in
the campaign
they will start to appear in levels
giving you access to reality bending
powers such as slowing time and
reversing gravity on the fly
though none of the four powers the masks
bestow are wildly original
they are all used to great effect
slowing down time at the exact right
moment to create a clear path of
platforms requires just as much thought
and reflexes as jumping and spinning
and sequences with each power come with
their own lessons to learn and quirks to
master
in addition each world includes optional
levels that allow you to play as some of
crash's friends
including tana dingodile and dr neo
cortex
each of the alternate characters have
their own skill sets
cortex for example cannot spin or double
jump but instead has a gun that turns
enemies into platforms and an air dash
levels built around these skill sets
create even more room for variety
you'll see new situations and need to
approach challenging platforming puzzles
differently
the downside is that switching from any
of these characters to crash or coco or
vice versa
can lead to some muscle memory mix-ups
and accidental deaths
it's a momentary annoyance but one that
creates a slightly bitter aftertaste
whenever you play one of these levels
especially during the campaign and
mastery is
crucial from early on crash 4 insists on
precision
many platforming sequences demand you
land multiple jumps in rapid succession
with perfect accuracy
and timing sometimes the difficulty is
invigorating
an action-packed puzzle for your mind
and fingers occasionally though it feels
as if the game expects more of you than
it should
there are times when you'll land on the
edge of a platform and fall to your
death
only to wonder whether or not you should
have been safe those frustrations are
fleeting though
more often the next success is close
enough in hand that you'll want to keep
trying
and merely finishing the campaign barely
scratches the surface of the experience
crash 4 is truly a perfectionist delight
each level offers up gemstones and a
character skin depending on how many
wampa fruit you find
how many boxes you break and how few
times you die
each level also boasts a time trial mode
and an inverted mirror level which not
only makes you play it mirrored
but also with a creative visual filter
that may make it easier or harder
the inverted levels are especially
interesting as they let you see crash
4's vibrant levels in a completely
different light
even more so than playing the insane
trilogy which literally remade the
original crash games from my youth
playing crash 4 felt like getting back
in touch with the series
it's an injection of new ideas into now
classic gameplay that surprises and
delights
even as it feels like a homecoming truly
games like this
are why we come running back to long
dormant franchises with open arms